in the last several videos we did some
fairly hairy mathematics and you might
have even skipped them but we got to a
pretty neat result we got to a formula
for the slope and y-intercept of the
best-fitting regression line when you
measure the error by the squared
distance to that line and our formula is
and I'll just rewrite it here just so we
have something neat to look at so the
slope of that line is going to be the
mean of X's times the mean of the Y's
minus the mean of the X YS and don't
worry this seems really confusing we're
going to actually do an example of this
actually in a few seconds divided by the
mean of x squared minus the mean of the
X Squared's and if this looks a little
different than what you see in your
statistics class or your textbook you
might see this swapped around if you
multiply both the numerator and the
denominator by negative one you could
you could see this written as the mean
of the X wise minus the mean of x times
the mean of the Y's all of that over the
mean of the X Squared's minus the mean
of the X is squared these are obviously
the same thing they're just you multiply
the numerator and the denominator by
negative one which is the same thing as
multiplying the whole thing by one and
of course whatever you get for y sort
whatever you get for M you can then just
substitute back in this back over here
to get your be your B is going to be
equal to the mean of the Y's - your M
whatever M value you got over here let
me write that in yellow so you get it's
very clear you solved for the M value
here minus M times the mean of the X's
minus M times the mean of the X's and
this is all you need so let's actually
put that into practice let's actually
put that into practice so let's say I
have let's say I have three points and
I'm going to make sure that these points
aren't collinear because that otherwise
it wouldn't be interesting so let me
draw three points over here
let's say that one point is the point 1
1 comma 2 so this is 1/2 so we have the
point right over here we have the point
1 comma 2 and then we also have the
point let's say we also have the point
oh I don't know let's let's say we also
have the point 2 comma 1 let's say we
have the point 2 comma 1 and then let's
say we also have the point let's say we
also have the point 3 comma I don't know
let's put do something let's do
something a little bit crazy let's do 3
comma 4 so 3 or that well let's let's do
it over here let's do 4 comma 3 just so
we can actually fit it on the page so 4
comma 3 is going to be something right
over here so this is 4 comma 3 so those
are our three points and what we want to
do is find the best fitting we want to
find the best fitting regression line
which we suspect is going to look
something we'll see what it looks like
but I suspect it's going to look
something like that
we'll see what it actually looks like
using our formulas which we have proven
which we have proven so a good place to
start is just to calculate these things
ahead of time and then just substitute
them back into the equation so what's
the mean of our X's the mean of our X is
the mean of our X's is going to be 1
plus I'll do the same colors 1 plus 2 1
plus 2 plus 4 plus 4 divided by I'll do
this in a neutral color the mean over X
is divided by 3 and what's this going to
be 1 plus 2 is 3 + 4 7 divided by 3 it
is equal to 7 over 3 now what is the
mean of our Y's the mean of our Y's once
again I want to do this in a neutral
color the mean of our Y's is equal to 2
is equal to 2 plus 1 plus 1 plus 3 plus
3 all of that over 3 so this is 2 plus 1
is 3 plus 3 is 6 divided by 3 is equal
to 2 sorry is equal to 2 this is 6
divided by 3 is equal to 2 now what is
the mean what is the mean of our what is
the mean of our X wise what is the mean
of our X wise well over here it's going
to be
so our first XY over here is 1 x 2 so
it's going to be 1 times 2 plus 2 times
1 plus 2 times 1 plus 4 times 3 plus 4
times 3 and we have three of these X YS
so divided by 3 so what's this going to
be equal to we have 2 plus 2 which is 4
4 plus 12 which is 16 so it's going to
be 16 over 3 I get that right 4 plus 12
yep 16 over 3 and then the last one we
have to calculate is the mean of the X
Squared's so what's the mean of the x
squared so the first x squared is just
going to be 1 squared this one squared
right over here plus this 2 squared plus
2 squared right over here plus this 4
squared plus this 4 squared and we have
three data points again so this is 1
plus 4 which is 5 plus 16 5 plus 16 is
equal to 21 over 3 which is equal to 7
so that worked out to a pretty neat
number so let's actually find our MS and
our and our B's so our slope are optimal
slope for this for our regression line
the mean of the X's it's going to be 7/3
7 over 3 times the mean of the Y's the
mean of the Y's is 2 minus the mean of
the X Y's well that's 16 over 3 16 over
3 and then all of that all of that over
the mean of the X is the mean of the X
is a 7/3
squared so 7 over 3 squared minus the
mean of the x squared so it's going to
be minus this 7 right over here and now
we just have to do a little bit of
mathematics here I'm tempted to get out
my calculator but I'll resist the
temptation it's nice to keep things as
fractions so let's see if I can
calculate this so this is going to be
equal to this is 14 over 3 14 over 3
minus 16 over 3
all of that over this is 49 49 over nine
right 7/3 squared is 49 over nine and
then minus seven if I wanted to express
that as something over nine that's the
same thing as sixty-three that's the
same thing as 63 over nine and so in our
numerator we get negative two thirds
negative two over three and then in our
denominator
what's 49 minus 63 that's negative let's
see that's negative fourteen that's
negative fourteen over nine and this is
the same thing as negative two-thirds
times nine over fourteen negative nine
over fourteen divide numerator and
denominator by three well the negatives
are going to cancel out first of all we
divide by three that becomes a one that
becomes a three divided by two becomes a
one that becomes a seven so our slope is
3/7 not too bad now we can go back and
figure out our y-intercept so let's
figure out our y-intercept using this
right over here so our y-intercept B is
going to be equal to the mean of the Y's
the mean of the Y's is two minus our
slope we just figured out our slope to
be 3/7 so minus 3/7 times the mean of
the X's which is 7/3 times 7/3 well
these these just are the reciprocal of
each other so they cancel out that just
becomes one so our y-intercept is
literally just two minus one so it
equals one so we have the equation for
our line our regression line is going to
be y is equal to we figured out M M is
3/7 Y is equal to 3/7 X plus our
y-intercept is 1 plus 1 and we are done
we are done so let's actually try to
graph this so our y-intercept is going
to be 1 it's going to be right over
there and the slope of our line is three
sevens
so for every seven we run we rise three
or another way to think of it for every
three and a half we run we rise one and
a half so we're going to go one
1/2 right over here so this line if you
were to graph it and obviously I'm hand
drawing it so it's not going to be that
exact is going to look like is going to
look like that right over there it
actually won't go directly it actually
won't go directly through that line so I
don't want to give you that impression
so it might look something like this at
this line we have shown that this
formula minimizes the squared distances
from each of these points to that line
anyway that was at least in my mind
pretty neat